Hoss no no no but we are looking for a
lost toy
she's a figurine used to be on that lamp
in the window name's Bo Peep Bo Peep oh
yes I know Bo you do hop on in we'll
take you to her grab well okay this is
the scene where woody meets Bo Yeah
right nine years later in the playground
and so we'll start here where bo over
here is that we stole hell yeah yeah and
if you remember the bow is lost girl
outside so she has no idea what he's
past and this is what he's she's
learning about that no no no no he he
went off to college but he gave us to
Bonnie she's this you have a little girl
no way yeah yeah it's why I'm out here
her other toy is trapped in this antique
store and I have two second-chance
antiques we know that store that's great
that is great if you know the store you
could really help me find him let's try
one more way where you're really
flailing here for she's gonna walk away
oh okay these are this is every attempt
to try and pull her back to okay she's
done she's not gonna go do it and I have
to I have to pull out the heavy
artillery okay all right no no no but
hey but you see body needs him just like
Molly needed you you like that upper
register I still have since 95 still
have a squeaky thirteen-year-olds voice
they say it's gonna change one of these
years
well that's woody right there's a great
woody line here which is but he gave us
the body Bonnie needs him to get through
kindergarten look who jumped 40 school
buses and landed back into my life
hi Duke who's the cowboy Duke meet woody
what do you mean
Duke kaboom Canada's greatest stunt man
huh oh yeah huh huh
yes huh - hold on one
more oh yeah great sooo one more and the
same kind of idea where Duke is just
reciting the commercial it's constantly
playing in his head there right but do
you want do you want Duke doing the
commercial or do you want what the Duke
like should I be doing the voiceover of
the commercial like Duke kaboom Canada's
greatest stuntman but if it was the
commercial maybe it would be different
like Duke kaboom Canada's greatest
stuntman look who jumped 40 school buses
and landed back into my life
hi Duke who's the cowboy Duke woody uh
Duke meet woody woody mean Duke kaboom
Canada's greatest stuntman huh oh yeah
ha ha ha ha he's posing Duke Duke we
need to hold on one more oh yeah
what brings you back Pete we need your
help Gabby Gabby has his toy and my
sheep no Billy Goats Gruff
those are my girls she thinks he is yeah
he's been she lost a while exactly she
learns that he has a kid still look no
later on seven fantastic years 7 you
would not believe the things that I have
seen when you're talking about the rag
doll he told you about it's like you
you're telling her the secret you guys
had talked about him right gossips about
him over the years is that a whisper
yeah looks like she's alright on her
shoulder so you're just being you don't
want woody to hear it whoa who's this
you remember the rag doll I told you
about the cowboy yep no way don't stare
I'm totally staring
woody this is giggle Mick dimples hey
nice find girls where do you get all
this stuff here and there you know some
kids play rougher than others so I try
to be prepared how long have you been
out on your own seven fantastic years
seven you would not believe the things I
have seen all right this is giggles
intro into the film and woody has just
met with Bo and now if I was gonna
introduce cables to would Ethan gigs yo
come on out there's someone I'd like you
to meet be right down
so what's the situation we had an out of
town or whoa who's this you
the ragdoll I told you about the cowboy
yep no way don't stare
I'm totally staring okay let's try one
more where when we're here with giggle
here she says what's the situation she's
in full police officer mode and then
when she sees woody she snaps right out
of it for what who's this okay that's
the same thing where she realizes he's a
cop she goes right into his shop and top
talking shop with him got it okay okay
perfect
gigs yo come on out there someone I'd
like you to meet be right down what's
the situation
so we heading out of town or whoa who's
this you remember the rag doll I told
you about the cowboy yep no wait don't
stare I'm totally staring whoa you tell
me he was a cop howdy Sheriff officer
giggle mcdhh impuls here and pet patrol
from minneapolis yeah
search and rescue and caterpillars
miniature poodles spiders okay this is
the scene this is the intro of ducky
money yep yep and so just remember that
buzz is tied in to the game and you guys
are so angry that he's there that's
right
so I'll read opposite you with bunny and
Buzz okay hey Lightyear hey up here
astro boy if you think you could just
show up and take our top prize spot
you're wrong you did roll you don't
understand I'm trying to cheat the
system and get with a kid yeah we know
no I need a childish shower you with
unconditional love
join the club pal come on help me get
out of here I'll help you with bunny
what are you doing hmm
I can't reach a man help me out here
come on oh sorry ducky yet I'm not a
mind-reader you know what's not to
understand huh you gonna make me say it
what with these tiny legs I cannot reach
without your help
record on the first page if you just be
more angry at this guy like really he's
he's ruined your chances of ever getting
with a kid right right gosh dang
you can do with them angry Zig me okay
this is the one in the RV we're just
talking about where it's between Buzz
and Woody what he's sitting there this
is the yeah I think it first learns
about the inner voice is this it yeah
this is it I'm gonna take the next watch
Oh keep an eye on porky no no no I need
to do this a little voice inside me we
never leave me alone if I gave up what
do you think it is who the voice inside
eeeh who do you think it is fascinating
so your inner voice advises you what all
right
so this is where Woody has is missing
and Buzz gonna go into action here in
the RV so then on the bed the whispering
to each other and Buzz realizes that
what he was right thing the entire time
there's a secret mission in uncharted
space no time to explain
attack all right this is scene we're
gonna do next is the the interesting of
Gabby Gabby and so woody in for Kia come
into the store and we're gonna start
here where Gabby Woody's talking about
Bo Peep and the first time I see them in
person Dexter oh the story's about to
open don't worry we'll take you where no
one will see us oh no no we can't stay
yes you can
Bo Peep oh yes I know Bo you do hop on
in we'll take you to her
oh you don't have to do that Benz mix it
up oh well okay Benson be careful with
our new friends well I want service uh
thank you for your help I haven't seen
Bo in years may I ask when were you made
you you really you're just trying to get
to figure out exactly what you need and
so when we get to page two well as soon
as he's saying oh thanks for your help
you go right into excuse me when were
you made so like your your goal has
completely changed to your own personal
goals thank you got him in your trap and
now you
start picking away out gee I wonder if
we were made in the same Factory
wouldn't that be something I gotta say
you are in great condition um great
let's try one more where you're being
very defiant here yes temper tantrum
what yes it not that oh and then we know
you get to here like here's the one
thing you do know like this this and
this okay no no I am NOT a toy I'm a
sport be quiet I was made for soup salad
maybe chili and then the trash I am let
me give you a different direction but
it's pretty much the same direction
really try and forcibly to understand
that you are not a toy whoever I give
you like you he's been running this for
for-4 seems in your knees listen you're
not getting it right I'm trash porky
porky I am NOT a toy
I'm a spork be quiet I was made for soup
salad maybe chili and then the trash
I'm winner I'm trash trash trash trash
trash trash trash
you